>> HE WAS READY.
HE WAS READY FOR HIS MOMENT, AND
IT WAS A BIG ONE.
>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
MORE NOW OF OUR INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S SON HUNTER.
IN HUNTER BIDEN'S NEW MEMOIR HE
ADDRESSES HIS LIFELONG BATTLE
WITH ADDICTION AND HIS FAMILY'S
EFFORTS TO SAVE HIM FROM
HIMSELF.
"BEAUTIFUL THINGS" COMES OUT
TOMORROW.
IT'S PUBLISHED BY GALLERY BOOKS,
AN IMPRINT OF SIMON & SCHUSTER
WHICH IS A DIVISION OF
VIACOMCBS.
WE SPOKE WITH BIDEN ABOUT THE
ROLE HE SAYS ANXIETY AND TRAUMA
PLAYED IN PUSHING HIM TO ALCOHOL
AND CRACK.
>> MOST PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH WHAT I'VE GONE THROUGH
ARE DEAD OR IN JAIL.
>> HUNTER BIDEN'S BATTLE WITH
ADDICTION BEGAN WITH A FEELING
OF LONELINESS HE SAYS HE'S FELT
SINCE HE WAS A CHILD.
>> IT'S THE FEELING OF NEVER
FITTING IN.
IT'S THAT HOLE.
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS
EXACTLY.
>> WHERE DO YOU THINK THAT
FEELING CAME FROM?
>> I AM MORE CONVINCED NOW THAT
TRAUMA IS AT THE CENTER OF.
>> COME TRAUMA?
LOSS OF YOUR MOTHER?
>> YEAH.
I -- ABSOLUTELY.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHY I HAD SUCH
A HARD TIME EVER ADMITTING THAT.
>> HUNTER'S MOTHER, NEILIA BIDEN
AND HIS 1-YEAR-OLD SISTER WERE
KILLED IN A CAR CRASH IN 1972.
HE AND HIS OLDER BROTHER BEAU,
JUST 2 AND 3 AT THE TIME, WERE
CRITICALLY INJURED BUT SURVIVED.
THEIR FATHER WAS SWORN IN TO HIS
FIRST TERM AS A SENATOR BY THEIR
HOSPITAL BEDSIDE.
>> I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
RESEARCH NOW THAT POINTS TO THE
IDEA THAT ALMOST ALL ADDICTS WHO
SUFFER FROM ADDICTION HAVE A
SERIOUS TRAUMA IN THEIR LIVES.
>> Reporter: BEAU AND I, HE
WRITES, NEVER REALLY GRIEVED THE
LOSS OF OUR MOTHER OR OUR BABY
SISTER.
YOU DIDN'T TALK ABOUT IT WITH
YOUR DAD EITHER?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT MY MOM ALL
THE TIME WITH MY DAD.
BUT THE ACTUAL ACCIDENT, NO.
THE DARKNESS THAT I'M -- I KNOW
MY DAD SUFFERED AFTERWARDS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
NECESSARILY TALKED ABOUT UNTIL
MUCH LATER.
>> DO YOU WISH YOU HAD NOW?
>> NO.
AND THIS IS WHERE I AM -- IT'S
HARD.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS WHY I DON'T WANT TO
ADMIT THAT -- WE PROBABLY SHOULD
HAVE.
I THINK THEY WERE TRYING TO
PROTECT US.
>> THE BOOK CHRONICLES BIDEN'S
LIFELONG STRUGGLES WITH ALCOHOL
AND COCAINE.
AT ONE POINT, HE MANAGED TO STAY
CLEAN FOR MORE THAN SEVEN YEARS.
WHEN HIS BROTHER BEAU DIED OF
BRAIN CANCER IN 2015, HUNTER
BEGAN A FOUR-YEAR DESCENT INTO
THE DARKEST PERIOD OF HIS
ADDICTION.
WHAT HE CALLS A BLUR OF COMPLETE
AND UTTER DEBAUCHERY.
>> DRINKING A QUART OF VODKA A
DAY BY MYSELF IS COMPLETELY
DEBILITATING.
>> THAT WAS JUST THE BEGINNING.
>> YOU'RE SMOKING CRACK AROUND
THE CLOCK, DRINKING INSANELY
LETHAL AMOUNTS OF ALCOHOL.
>> WE WANT BIDEN, WE WANT THE
SON, HUNTER, WHERE'S HUNTER?
>> BY 2019 HE'D BECOME A TARGET
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> 10% HELD BY HUNTER FOR THE
BIG GUY.
THE BIG GUY.
>> IT DIDN'T CHANGE MY BEHAVIOR
IN ANY WAY.
I STILL NEEDED TO GET HIGH.
I STILL NEEDED TO HIDE.
I STILL NEEDED TO FILL THAT
HOLE.
>> AS HIS FATHER WAS PLANNING A
PRESIDENTIAL RUN, BIDEN, WHO'D
LEFT BEHIND THREE DAUGHTERS AND
A FAILED MARRIAGE, WAS LIVING
OUT OF ROADSIDE MOTELS, CHASING
HIS NEXT FIX.
THEN THE FAMILY PLANNED A
DRAMATIC INTERVENTION DISGUISED
AS AN INVITATION TO A FAMILY
DINNER.
WHY DID YOU AGREE TO GO?
>> MY MOM SAID SHE'D MISS ME.
>> YEAH.
>> SHE SAID, DAD REALLY --
REALLY NEEDS YOU.
>> YEAH.
BUT YOU WERE NOT IN ANY
CONDITION TO GO --
>> NO.
I WALK IN, AND -- AND THERE ARE
MY THREE GIRLS, MY NIECE AND
NEPHEW, MY MOM AND DAD, AND TWO
COUNSELORS FROM A REHAB CENTER
I'D BEEN TO BEFORE.
I LOOKED AND SAID, NOT A CHANCE.
NO WAY --
>> YOU EXPLODED.
>> EXPLODED.
LITERALLY BEGAN TO RUN UP THE
DRIVEWAY.
>> AND YOUR FATHER CHASED YOU?
>> YEAH.
HE GRABBED ME IN A HUG --
GRABBED ME.
HE PUT -- BEAR HUG.
HE SAID, JUST CRIED, SAID, "I
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO."
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN YOU
HEARD THAT?
>> I THOUGHT I NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO TELL HIM THAT I'M
GOING TO DO SOMETHING SO THAT I
CAN GO TAKE ANOTHER HIT.
>> YEAH.
>> THE ONLY THING I COULD THINK.
I DON'T KNOW OF A FORCE MORE
POWERFUL THAN MY FAMILY'S LOVE
EXCEPT ADDICTION.
I SAID I WAS GOING TO GET HELP,
BOOKED THE NEXT FLIGHT TO LOS
ANGELES, AND DECIDED THAT I WAS
GOING TO COMPLETELY DISAPPEAR
FOREVER.
>> BUT BEFORE HE DISAPPEARED,
BIDEN AGREED TO AN INTERVIEW
WITH THE "NEW YORKER."
>> IT'S PART OF THE THING THAT
SAVED ME, THOUGH.
I STARTED TO TELL MY STORY.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOKED AT THE
ARTICLE AND THOUGHT, WHY ARE YOU
DOING THIS TO YOUR DAD RIGHT
NOW.
>> YEAH.
AND I LOOKED AT IT AS I WAS
GOING TO TAKE AWAY THEIR
AMMUNITION.
>> YEAH.
>> THE ONE THING THAT I THOUGHT
THAT THEY WOULD TRY TO USE
AGAINST HIM WAS MY DRUG
ADDICTION.
THIS IDEA THAT I WAS A CRACK
ADDICT.
>> YEAH.
YOU WANTED TO PUT IT OUT THERE
BEFORE THEY COULD USE IT AGAINST
YOU AND AGAINST YOUR FATHER.
>> YEAH.
EXACTLY.
AND -- AND NO ONE IN THE
CAMPAIGN KNEW I WAS BECAUSE I
KNEW THEY'D SAY NO.
>> WHAT HAPPENED NEXT, BIDEN
CALLS A MIRACLE.
ON A BLIND DATE, HE MET MELISSA
COHEN, AN ASPIRING FILMMAKER
FROM SOUTH AFRICA.
THEY HAD AN INSTANT CONNECTION.
>> THEN I TOLD HER AN HOUR LATER
IT I SAID, I'M -- I'M A CRACK
ADDICT.
>> AND SHE DIDN'T RUN AWAY.
>> SHE SAID, WELL, THAT ENDS
NOW.
>> DID YOU THINK IT WAS YOUR
LAST CHANCE?
>> YES.
I KNEW IT WAS MY LAST CHANCE.
>> JUST SEVEN DAYS LATER, THEY
WERE MARRIED.
LAST YEAR, THEIR SON BEAU WAS
BORN.
WITH MELISSA'S HELP, HUNTER
BIDEN BEGAN TO REPAIR THE
DAMAGE.
ONE OF THE DEEPEST WOUNDS TO HIS
FAMILY, THE AFFAIR HE HAD WITH
HIS BROTHER'S WIDOW HALLIE JUST
AFTER BEAU'S DEATH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK -- WHAT
WERE YOU THINKING?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
>> BOTH OF US HAD GONE THROUGH
THE MOEFST INCREDIBLY PAINFUL
LOSS, AND IT WAS OUT OF LOVE,
AND I THOUGHT THAT MAYBE THAT
LOVE WOULD BRING MY BROTHER
BACK.
>> UH-HUH.
>> AND IT DIDN'T WORK.
>> IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT, DID
YOU THINK ABOUT HOW YOUR OWN
KIDS WOULD LOOK AT THIS?
>> YEAH.
AND -- AND IT WAS HARD.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY.
IT WAS REALLY HARD.
>> IN THE NEARLY TWO YEARS HE
SAYS HE'S BEEN SOBER, HUNTER
BIDEN HAS TRIED TO MAKE AMENDS.
>> HARDEST AMEND FOR ME TO MAKE
WAS TO MY BROTHER.
>> BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T MAKE
THAT IN PERSON?
>> I HAD -- I MADE A PROMISE TO
HIM THAT I WOULD -- I WOULD BE
OKAY.
>> YOU FELT LIKE YOU LET HIM
DOWN.
>> YEAH.
>> HOW DO YOU MAKE PEACE WITH
TH
THAT?
>> LIVE EVERY DAY IN HONOR OF
THAT.
BEING A PURPOSE AND OF SERVICE
TO OTHER PEOPLE THAT I KNOW IS
WHAT I NEED TO DO.
>> YOU KNOW, AS YOU READ THIS
BOOK, THERE ARE MOMENTS WHEN YOU
GET HONESTLY INFURIATED BECAUSE
HE KEEPS MAKING BAD DECISIONS.
AND I -- BEFORE THIS INTERVIEW,
I CALLED A FRIEND OF MINE WHO
HAD BEEN THROUGH ADDICTION AND
RECOVERY, AND I SAID, PLEASE
EXPLAIN THIS BECAUSE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
AND HE MADE THE POINT THAT
HUNTER MAKES IN -- WHEN HE WAS
CONFRONTED BY HIS FATHER IN THE
DRIVEWAY.
HE SAID, THE THING YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IS THERE IS NOTHING
MORE POWERFUL THAN ADDICTION,
NOT EVEN YOUR FAMILY'S LOVE.
HE SAID, FOR YOU TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HE WENT THROUGH, YOU ARE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT.
-- YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT WAS THE POINT OF EMPATHY I
FOUND.
AS YOU SEE, HE'S MADE A LOT OF
VERY DUBIOUS JUDGMENTS OVER
TIME.
AND IT -- YOU STRUGGLE TO COME
TO TERMS WITH THAT.
>> HIS FATHER WAS CERTAINLY
THERE FOR HIM ALL THE TIME, HIS
MOM -- DR. JILL BIDEN, HIS MOM,
TOO.
CERTAINLY NEVER SEEMED TO HAVE
GIVEN UP ON HIM.
>> THEY NEVER GAVE UP ON HIM.
HIS FATHER INTERVENED BEFORE THE
INCIDENT HE DESCRIBES AT ONE
POINT IN WASHINGTON AND
LITERALLY SAVED HIM THEN, TOO.
>> IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO PULL THE
POLITICS OUT OF IT, I'M LEFT
WITH SYMPATHY FOR A FAMILY
RIPPED AND WOUNDED BY THIS.
I MEAN, NO MATTER HOW GOOD A
PARENT YOU ARE OR HOW BAD A
PARENT YOU ARE, THIS CAN HAPPEN
TO YOUR FAMILY.
WE'RE SEEING IT PLAY OUT IN VERY
PUBLIC DETAIL.
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE QUESTIONING
THE TIMING OF THE BOOK.
I THINK RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE --
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION --
>> YEAH.
I WONDERED --
>> IS THIS CATHARTIC FOR HIM --
>> THAT'S WHAT MY FRIEND TOLD
ME.
HE SAID THE THING YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IS WHEN YOU SAY
ALLOWED -- TELLING THE STORY
ALLOWED AND BEING HONEST WITH
HIMSELF WAS VERY CATHARTIC.
HE SAID, HE SAID THAT'S WHAT
THIS BOOK MEANS TO HIM.
IT'S PART OF THE CATHARSIS.
>> IF IT HELPS HIM